[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 29 avril début
d'une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal tout de suite les
titres
le secours populaire français orphelin
de son président julien lauprêtre est
décédé vendredi à l'âge de 93 ans à la
tête de la structure depuis 1955 il
avait fait de l'association l'une des
plus importantes agissant pour la
solidarité en france invité de ce
journal pascal rodier secrétaire général
du secours populaire des yvelines après
la suède la maison de l'europe des
yvelines était en grèce une délégation
s'est rendue dans la nation hellénique
pour la suite de riz dit un projet
européen de rencontres transnationales
déplacement de quatre jours pour
échanger sur la ruralité et puis une
course en compagnie de fidèles
compagnons dimanche le dixième canicross
prenez son départ en forêt de sainte
apolline à plaisir en événements
organisés par le refuge spa de la ville
pour sensibiliser à l'adoption des
chiens
cette information avant de développer
ces titres une jeune femme de 23 ans
poignardée cet après midi à trappes
elle a reçu cinq à six coups de couteau
dans le ventre les faits se sont
déroulés vers 14 heures 30 au square
henri wallon est l'agresseur serait son
demi frère qui s'est rendu aux autorités
le motif et les circonstances de cet
acte restent encore à déterminer la
victime a été transféré en urgence à
l'hôpital percy de clamart dans les
hauts-de-seine
son état de santé n'est pas encore
connue avant de parler du secours
populaire le déplacement donc de la
maison de l'europe
en grèce la délégation française a
rejoint celle venant de pologne
d'allemagne et des pays-bas ou encore de
suède sur les îles de rhodes et de tilos
troisième rencontre transnationales dans
le cadre du projet riz dit un projet
européen pour la citoyenneté active dans
les zones rurales
le récit de nicolas landry les images
sont signés alexis garneau des yvelinois
au coeur de la campagne grecque avec
leurs partenaires européens la maison de
l'europe des yvelines a découvert l'île
de rhodes entre la mer egée et la mer
méditerranée et notamment le
savoir-faire des habitants de la ville
d'apollonia on a pu voir l'habitat
traditionnel également les différents
outils utilisés pour tisser mais aussi
tailler le bois presser les olives
récoltées ou obtenir en tout cas du miel
l'île de rhodes le poumon de l'archipel
dodécanèse composée de 160
il est près de 250000 habitants ses
paysages méditerranéens attire près de
2,5 millions de touristes par an à côté
des zones touristiques qui concentrent
beaucoup de touristes on a une culture
agricole très présentes nous avons des
îles isolées des îles - qui ont leurs
propres besoins parce que même une itt
de moins de 50 personnes a besoin d'un
accès à la santé à l'éducation
cela est un challenge pour beaucoup dit
joker face à l' isolement l'île de tilos
développe des panneaux photovoltaïques
et des éoliennes
objectif rendre les habitants autonome
en énergie
on couvre 100% des besoins énergétiques
divers de l'île de tilos et on ressent %
des besoins énergétiques de lille pour
l'hiver et ont fait un excellent de 30%
pour l'été redistribuer vers les autres
il tout cela pour réduire les
consommations de ce séjour s'inscrit
dans le projet riz dit
une collaboration entre plusieurs
associations de pays européens avec
comme but de partager les expériences
pour développer les zones rurales
prochaine étape au mois de juin en
pologne le secours populaire français a
perdu son président julien lauprêtre est
décédé vendredi à l'âge de 93 ans il
avait été hospitalisé à paris suite à
une chute et julien lauprêtre 60,82
présidence du secours populaire
il a fait grandir l'association
aujourd'hui qui est l'une des
principales en france pour la solidarité
envers les plus démunis
et pour parler de cette disparition
pascal rodier est avec nous un plateau
bonsoir enfin vous êtes le secrétaire
général du secours populaire des
yvelines je viens le prêtre qui était
venu à de nombreuses reprises sur le
territoire est ce que sa disparition
elle laisse un grand vide
c'est armand c'est à dire que quand une
personne comme vous ne l'avez dit a
porté à bout de bras l'association
pendant plus de 60 ans a commencé
dans un petit réseau de militants pour
en faire ce que ce qu'elle en est
devenue maintenant forcément les amis du
secours populaire sont tous à un petit
peu choqué qu un petit peu mais bon on
est une association de solidarité de
mise en mouvement et je pense que lui
même aurait pas trop voulu qu'on
ralentisse parce que les questions de
précarité continuez donc bien il n'y a
pas de ya pas de 16 pour ça il faut
aller de l'avant vous vous le dit alors
c'est une association qui a commencé
c'était une petite rupture à la base
d'une petite structure du parti
communiste est très vite
julien lauprêtre l'a fait la tournée en
tout cas là l'action principalement vers
la solidarité a laissé côté l'action
politique ça ça a été un tournant pour
pour l'association
en fait plus précisément c'est quand
même du fait
beaucoup des cadres du secours populaire
des français des deux français des
colonies en sont morts de faits de
résistance ou de déportation et des 45 à
la création du secours populaire le
secours populaire m'a marqué son
détachement on va dire systémique d'avec
le parti communiste et julien lauprêtre
qui est arrivé en 1954 5
et c'est vrai que tout de suite de toute
façon depuis 40 dès la création quand 45
l'association c'était de la solidarité
notamment de la solidarité vis-à-vis des
enfants et lui a été surnommé il a été
résistant il était surnommé l'abbé pire
lakes et hun sen sur nous qu'il a lu et
qui lui allait tout à fait je sais je
sais pas si leurs efforts bon il
connaissait bien l'abbé pierre je sais
pas si elle aurait apprécié la chose je
pense que en fait d'une certaine manière
était quand même pas trop sensible aux
hommages et en tout cas ce qu'il est
mais pas trop ces l'icônisation des gens
donc je fais un faut se méfier de ces
petits c petit parallèle la après l'abbé
pierre c'est quand même une grande
figure aussi sur l'aide alimentaire
c'est bien sur l'axé fort de
l'association il ya aussi un autre axe
sur lequel il a mis l'accent julien
lauprêtre c'est de mettre les enfants au
coeur de l'action du secours populaire
en fait je pense que oui vous avez
raison notamment grâce aux mouvements
d'enfants copains du monde ce qui nous a
permis de venir ici à plusieurs reprises
pour parler des villages d'enfants
copains du monde notamment
c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui de
par son histoire personnelle de tout
petits en fête a pu bénéficier quand
yves c'est un enfant d'ouvrier un de
cheminots plus précisément la pu
bénéficier de la solidarité ouvrière à
l'époque est donc de 2 tout jeune les
idées de faire partir des enfants à la
mère de leur faire découvrir les joies
des vacances et tout ça c'est quelque
chose qui qui portait on va dire dans
son adn quasiment et donc du coup
l'action vis-à-vis des enfants
c'était quelque chose de précieux qu'il
est l'enfance c'est notre avenir et vous
lisez malgré cette action importante de
julien lauprêtre la présence
d'associations comme le secours
populaire n'a jamais été aussi
nécessaire en france depuis millions de
personnes qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté ring dans les unes vous étiez
venu nous parler de ses plus de neuf
mille bénéficiaires de l'aide
alimentaire en 2000
8 ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il reste
encore tout à faire bah oui
et en plus dans beaucoup de domaines la
situation s'aggrave parce qu'elle se
complexifie c'est à dire que avant il y
avait une vision un petit peu plus
binaire pour résoudre la pauvreté
c'était essentiellement de l'ordre de
l'économique et comme elle s'est
installée depuis plusieurs dit plusieurs
décennies cette pauvreté on va dire
systémique et ben ça complexifie la
situation des gens et donc du coup ça
fait que les solidarités doivent être de
plus en plus étendues et on va dire
qualitative même si le mot est peut-être
pas forcément adapté mais en tout cas
diversifié donc c'est vrai que c'est des
tâches qui sont de plus en plus lourdes
on va dire assumer pour le mouvement
associatif en général et pour le secours
populaire en particulier puisque nous
avons eu le bon goût de nous déclarer
généraliste et donc forcément comme on
essaye d'être cohérent avec le discours
ça nécessite d'être présent sur tous les
fronts quoi on crée des défis qui se
posent aujourd'hui pour marcher sur les
traces de julien lauprêtre une dernière
question quel héritage il laisse d'après
vous la capacité de l'esprit de
résistance en fait c'est quelque chose
qui a construit sa vie puisqu'il a été
compagnon de cellule du groupe
manouchian un peu par hasard mais c'est
quand même quelque chose qui a été un
tournant dans sa vie
et cet esprit de résistance il avait le
talent et
la capacité et l'empathie pour le
communiqué vis-à-vis de tout le monde et
donc en fait c'est le fait de ne pas se
résigner aussi qui certainement le plus
les plus beaux messages en fait qu'on
peut laisser quoi c'est à dire qu'il
faut jamais cesser de combattre jamais
se résigner il faut jamais perdre espoir
merci pascal rodier pour cette réaction
près secrétaire général pardon du
secours populaire des yvelines une fête
des fleurs à présent solidarité avec les
personnes atteintes de cécité la 16e
édition de la prairial s'est tenu ce
week end à la ferme du manet de montigny
le bretonneux en plus des fleurs et des
plantes et les visiteurs ont pu acheter
des produits du terroir et de
l'artisanat l'intégralité des bénéfices
a été reversée à l'école des chiens
guides les propos sont recueillis par
marylène iapichino c'est une fête de
printemps où la période est la meilleure
pour les plantations et aussi découvrir
de nouveaux produits qu'ils soient des
yvelines où d'ailleurs produits
gourmands un artisanat qui vient bien
régulièrement chaque année cinq chiens
ont été achetés et ont pu être données à
des habitants de la ville nouvelle
le coût d'un chien et entre 20000 et 25
millions et vous avez peut-être entendu
beaucoup d'abba d'aboiements ce week-end
en forêt de sainte apolline à plaisir le
refuge spa organisé son 1/10 canicross
une course avec son chien ou l'un des
pensionnaires du site marylène yapi
chinois a suivi l'événement aujourd'hui
macao est sorti de son enclos il a la
chance de pouvoir courir avec wonder
woman les gros lot lui comme ça les gens
ont peur je la revends donc moi je suis
là chaque année pour sortir les gros le
duo participe à la 10e édition du
canicross du refuge spa de plaisir une
centaine de chiens
certains du refuge certains avec leurs
maîtres et de toutes tailles et au
départ dans la forêt de sainte apolline
et s'appelle forte parce qu'elle aime
bien être toujours en prenez donc c'est
toujours utile
c'est vraiment de très bons moments
passés avec mon chien très grande
complicité
pour cette course anniversaire des
étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ont participé
aux projets de cette association qui
leur tenait à coeur la ressource de
partenariat pour la collation pour les
médailles et aussi au niveau tout ce qui
est communication sur l'événement en
recherche de bénévoles et c'est un
parcours de 5 km avec des gamelles de
ravitaillement bien nécessaire et lynda
reeves est méritée pour les canidés
maîtres et chiens sont fiers de poser
sur un dogue walk imaginé pour
l'occasion on a des chiens craintif qui
ont couru et une fois qu'ils courent ils
oublient tout don qui sont à fond dans
la course et avec leurs maîtres
donc ça leur fait oublier leur peur donc
voilà c'est pour tout ça que le sport
avec un chien peut apporter énormément
si l'aventuré à six pattes vous a plu il
existe une fédération des sports et
loisirs canins avec plus de 100 clubs en
france dont un à coignières retour du
journal le lundi autour des résultats
sport de mickaël millero bonsoir et
alors il y avait notamment ce week end
qu'elle un gros match de hockey sur
gazon
effectivement il y aurait je vois que
vous êtes toujours aussi assidus à ce
résultat sportif et ce week-end c'était
le choc de cette dernière journée élite
le racing club de france 4e recevez ce
dimanche 28 avril à versailles le stade
français classé troisième après une
première période équilibrée les locaux
ont réussi à prendre l'ascendant pour
l'emporter sur le score de 5 à 2 on
écoute les réactions ça s'est plutôt
bien passé puisqu'on gagne 5 buts à deux
donc c'est plutôt un bon score on est
content du résultat
après sur la manière il ya quand même
des choses qui sont perfectibles ya eu
beaucoup d'erreurs techniques
je sais pas si c'est le terrain
notre niveau d'implication mais beaucoup
d'erreurs techniques qui ont fait que
certaines occasions qu'ils étaient bien
mises en place n'ont pas pu aboutir
on avait à coeur de bien finir cette
saison contre une équipe sur lequel on
avait perdu
au match aller et du coup voilà on a on
a un petit peu rétabli les choses et
c'était important
avec cette victoire le racing club de
france terminent la phase régulière à la
quatrième place ils joueront en
demi-finale de play-off contre leurs
voisins de saint jean les samedi
prochain un derby yvelinois qu'on a hâte
de voir on continue de parler de
versailles michael mais cette fois ci du
rugby les versaillais l'ont fait les
joueurs de la cité royale ont remporté
ce week-end de boucliers deux titres de
champion ile de france
la réserve l'emportent 29 à 28 face aux
skull sur terrain neutre et l'équipe
première a réussi à battre vincennes sur
le score de 17 à 12
on écoute le responsable communication
du club pierre chevallier nous parle de
cette saison historique
prochain objectif pour aller vers ça y
est allé chercher un titre de champion
de france honneur dans les prochaines
semaines pour cela ils devront battre
lille ce dimanche sur terrain neutre
on termine par du golfe michael un
événement qui ne vous est pas étranger
exactement j étais vous y étiez
également la ryder cup 2018 a été nommé
événement sportif de l'année ici à la
semaine dernière à londres par le
prestigieux bureau britannique de
l'industrie du sport le tournoi qui a vu
les européens s'imposer face aux états
unis sur le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines a accueilli près de
270 mille fans venus du monde entier fin
septembre
evènement également battu le record
d'articles parus dans la presse et près
d'un milliard de personnes en vue cette
ryder cup française à la télévision
la prochaine édition aura lieu en 2020
dans le wisconsin aux états unis merci
michael on vous retrouve dans quelques
instants à la présentation du 7-8 sport
comme tous les lundis sur tv 78 c'est la
fin de ce journal édition à à consulter
également en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]